[Music]
reese witherspoon opens up about facing
psychological and verbal abuse in a past
relationship during an interview with
her wrinkle and time co-star Oprah
Winfrey as part of super soul Sunday the
41 year old actress gets candid about
the quote most difficult decision she
ever had to make
leaving an abusive relationship a line
got drawn in the sand and it got crossed
and my brain just switched and I knew it
was gonna be very difficult but I just
couldn't go any further
Witherspoon explains that it was this
moment that altered the trajectory of
her life I couldn't ever be the person I
am today I was a different person - it
changed who I was on a cellular level
the fact that I stopped for myself I'm a
different person now and it's part of
the reason I can stand up and say yes
I'm ambitious and yes because someone
tried to take that from me et caught up
with the actress at the Golden Globes in
January where she talked about the times
up movement aimed in part at fighting
abuse people who were so brave to tell
their stories first and we're standing
here because of the courage they had and
also women in all industries and men in
all industries are standing up and
saying enough with discrimination and
harassment and abuse we deserve equality
and the time is up
[Music]